so what's going on with you how you
handle it all this time
mostly we've just been doing school
trying to keep busy and what is what
school like for you because I mean so
much of school is the social aspect of
high school without when you take all
that out and then you have your kitchen
table and homework what school like for
you well I mean the social aspect is the
fun part of it for me so now you're just
left with the work but I have online
classes I'm on zum-zum with my whole
class so I pretty small classes there's
about ten of us in there we kind of like
do the lesson and then we end the call
which is kind of good actually because
we're only on for like half an hour
usually so I'm coming at the chill my
school days pretty short and and if you
if you did have to pay for data on your
phone how much do you think your bill
would be by the end of all of this oh
man actually probably not much because I
don't leave my house no I'm on my Wi-Fi
all the time oh right right right yeah
if I were to pay for my Wi-Fi though I
don't know so what do you like what are
you doing like how because you are like
a social person and you are you know you
do have fans and you do have friends
what is somebody like what are you doing
sort of right now to to sort of fill
that void that you can't connect with
people you know sort of in in life I
think I'm still connecting with people I
think it just not physically I'm doing
with my friends like all the time when
we're not in school and stuff and me and
my friends like play video games
together so we're all we're always doing
something always doing an activity and
aside from that like music-wise in
social media wise I taught myself how to
use Pro Tools which is like a music
recording software yeah I I started
recording my my vocals and stuff like
that we made an acoustic version of
phobias a song that I wrote a couple
months ago we
filmed the music video for Cu the song I
put out yesterday in my bedroom was your
actual bedroom that was my bedroom yeah
now do just feel like finding it it's a
make-work project every day did you film
it in your bedroom because of
coronavirus yes so the whole premise of
the video is kind of like well so the
meaning of the song is basically I like
lost somebody that was in my like I I
fell out of touch with somebody and I
eventually end up getting back into
touch with this person that and the
whole thing is that I want to see them I
want to see the really bad but you know
no I'm with coronavirus it's kind of
taking on a double meaning because I
can't see anybody so the the video is is
kind of like a day in my life in a
quarantine and it's me facetiming my
friends and messing around how many
guitars do you have oh yeah I think we
have four in the whole house my sister
now is that your computer in your room
like no like siblings can't use it
nobody else can use it that's like your
spot right so yeah but we actually that
was actually a camera so we just like
like yeah we dubbed over like this
finder and whatever else so but we but
yeah I have I have my computer in my
room my password hint is Lauren go back
to your room so were you supposed to do
you were supposed to do shows over March
Break
right I was yeah I was supposed to do
some shows at like Cineplex like it was
just gonna be like a small little cool
acoustic event yeah and so that all
obviously got canceled so how much are
you just like dying to get back out in
front of an idea like I've been thinking
about it so much recently the fruit the
last time I went on like a real tour was
last June yeah I believe last last
spring summer sometime and it was the
most fun of
probably ever so I miss it so much I
miss going to all the cities being with
my friends because my fans you know idea
its it it like hurts me to talk about it
who so are you did I read this right
like you're are you getting your
driver's license or have you got your
driver's license yet so I have my g1 and
and my g2 test was scheduled for a
Friday of a week right yeah
so on the Monday drive test announces
that they're closing every single Center
in Ontario yeah like out of fear the
virus which I mean understandable but
huge sewer for me because now I have to
wait until all this is over to get my
detail so now I don't I don't I don't
mean to be a huge buzz kill but I just
want to let you know that I was 42 when
I got my driver's license
yeah do you live like downtown yeah yeah
yeah I've never I've never needed it but
just so you know if this goes on for a
while 42 is the number to beat
if this goes on so with everything else
that's with everything else that's going
on and when you get when you decide to
shoot this video there's a ton of cameos
in the video from a lot of your friends
were any of them hard to nail down or
that they all just say yes immediately
because nobody doing anything right now
it was it was mostly yes immediately but
it was kind of hard to nail down no
because he like didn't know what I was
talking about
I'd say FaceTime I mean he was like okay
well I have to go for dinner it I was
like alright but he was cool they're all
good I was I was super thankful that
they were able to send videos yeah and
but and I forgot to ask are you a good
driver or you like rate your driving
skills I'm the best driver my sister's
have a good day and what do you think 1
to 10 my driving skills
she's just shaking your head five five
that's I think you
who in your life goups on you the most
every time you post a picture on
Instagram with your shirt off
[Laughter]
yeah even my dad or my friends like my
my boys will send it to me and be like
wow this guy's jacked a guy's huge
what's it like for you because I also
wonder with something like that like
well your dad just sit there and does he
read the comments or does he avoid the
comments no he loves it he loves hearing
what people have to say for better for
words because he gets very like like I
don't know how to describe hehe he gets
like like he feels like it's a personal
attack even though you know what I mean
and I just bag pretty much fully ignore
comments other than like my talk
comments which are all from people that
follow me which i think is a good move
by Instagram because like I'm protected
not perfect good for you and let's talk
about your hair real quick because
nobody can get a haircut anymore no I'm
just waiting it out I actually got I
shaved back right back here so I was
getting like the trails they come down
you know I mean did you get yourself
like all greasy no I got my sister do
Tommy oh that's a one time it's a one
time year you allowed your sister to
help you out with something right yeah
of course she actually heard a lot of
stuff she shoot my social media and
music and stuff yeah yeah and now are
you working towards is there an EP or an
album coming what's happening yeah so
the plan initially was to drop singles
for a little bit leading into the summer
and then do a project but there's really
no way to promote an album right now or
do anything like that not have them so
IEP yeah there's really there's really
no way to to launch it the right way so
I think we're gonna hold off for a
little bit also I just like putting out
singles because it helps me kind of like
test the water you see what people are
feeling